Hey Vsauce, I've got a quick and fun video
for you today because I made a mistake.
Last week on Episode 10 of ING,
I showed a picture and I said,
"cat and dogs cooperating."
However, if you look at the picture
for more than a second,
you can tell that it's not a cat.
It's a monkey.
When a commenter pointed that out to me,
my mind was blown.
And so now I'm going to return the favor.
Prepare to get blown
in the mind.
First stop, Super Mario Galaxy.
Many of you may have already discovered this,
but if you read each letter and only each letter
that has a star underneath it
on the cover of the game,
it spells out "U R MR GAY."
Mario!
But don't the worry.
We might get the last laugh.
Here it is, an online Flash game
you can play right now
called Duck Hunt, more specifically,
"Kill the Dog From Duck Hunt."
That's right. After all of these years,
you finally have the power.
Unfortunately, Nintendo may have one-upped us.
Remember this? After completing the castle,
it turns out Toad has been flipping us off
the entire time.
The Chicago Bulls logo upside down
is a robot reading a book,
and if you actually look closely, the Doom guy
has only ever had one gun.
More importantly, the poster for
Silence of the Lambs.
We've all seen it, but have you ever noticed
all of the naked women?
I'm serious. Let's get a little closer in on the skull.
Good. Do you see it? It's a portrait
by Salvadore Dalles.
And hey, what the H?
Let's do an audio illusion.
You're going to need headphones for this, but if you don't have them, I'll do a visual illusion simultaneously.
Okay, stare into the middle of these swirling shapes
and listen through your headphones.
You'll hear someone shaking a matchbook
three-dimensionally around you.
I spent more time yesterday than
I'd like to admit playing this game.
It's fun because you get to jump around,
but sometimes if you want to,
your jumps can have a little extra kick,
I guess because of your diet.
Okay, so puzzle farter probably didn't blow your mind,
but phew, it feels good to get off my chest
the fact that I love it.
One final fact, NERF is not just a silly word.
It's an acronym that stands
for non-expanding recreational foam,
also, I am made out of Vsauce.
I didn't really die, but if you have a secret about yourself,
leave it in the comments below.
And as always, thanks for watching.